hello and welcome to the concert hall in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel
laureates receive their awards from the
king of Sweden for their outstanding
contributions to science and economics
and they join a small and elite group
and this is the first time that they
will be appearing together on TV and
we've also invited their family and
friends through our audience as well as
some of the best and brightest students
from across Stockholm and they will be
putting their questions and comments to
our laureates
well this year we have discoveries in
the development of small machines a
thousand times thinner than a strand of
hair can you believe that
we also delve into strange forms of
matter that could lead to superfast
computing and does it make economic
sense to pay bosses big cheques salaries
bonuses that kind of thing well they're
amongst the topics that we'll be
discussing but this year's Nobel
laureates gentlemen welcome to you all
and renewed congratulations to all of
you
now I hope you don't mind my starting
off by saying that the average age of
this year's laureates is 72 year or 65
or over and you know the trend is to
award the Nobel prizes later in life do
you think it's a good thing that you
should wait longer to be recognized for
your work I'll ask you first
Oliver Hart because your father died at
the age of 106 and he published his most
significant scientific paper when he was
71 it's true yes I I think he was going
a little too slowly actually but yeah to
answer your question I I think certainly
in economics they tend to want to be
sure that the contribution that that
they're recognizing is is one that's
going to survive the test of time and I
can understand that because things
happen you know people get very excited
about things and there's some sort of
hot topic and then it turns out you know
5 10 years later it doesn't seem so
important so I think you know they often
wait 30 years and that's ok and that's
going to lead to the kind of ages you're
talking about at which people win prizes
hmm I mean could one of the reasons be
that there's so much theory now I mean
apparently a hundred years ago there
were a thousand physicists and now there
are apparently a million so what do the
physicists think do you think it takes
longer for real talent to shine through
because there's just so much information
you've got to assimilate I don't think
it takes longer it's just as you say
it's a matter of quantity there's so
many smart physicists around that how do
you tell which piece of work is going to
be significant it's impossible Ben
Farina as a chemist you think that the
prize acknowledges the kind of benefits
of incremental ism you know standing on
the shoulders of giants as it were and
it kind of goes against the starting
Eureka moment in the bar that we often
associate with science of course we
stand on the shoulders of giants I mean
we work with the knowledge that was made
experienced and develop before us but
there are these sudden moments that in
time that my colleagues and myself and
others in the field experience where you
suddenly realize the you have made a
breakthrough and that opens up a new
field it might take several years before
it's recognised that a new field has
been opened hmm but Jean Pierre survives
I mean you're a chemist but I could ask
you this and we're thinking about drugs
and vaccines and that kind of thing I
mean we do need fast science don't we to
fix urgent problems I mean like the Zika
virus or whatever because you know you
can't hang around for ages waiting for
vaccines yeah you're absolutely right
that you know we are I think probably
all of us around this table basic
scientists we are mostly interested in
basic science and of course I mean the
research we do I could lead to new drugs
new vaccines and all that but in our
everyday research we are quite far away
from that let me just see what the
students in our audience think students
just a cup you comments from some of you
about sort of life in the fast lane the
slow lane because I mean the world that
you inhabit today is quite different
from when these Nobel laureates started
studying I mean you've got you know
instant knowledge and information people
talk about information overload the
distractions the constant digital
stimulation you know confusing
information with knowledge who feels
that perhaps we should have more
emphasis on long term effort and
experience I think that maybe in reason
--jared technology may have affected
extruding the young young generation
negatively in that sense maybe they have
gotten less patients perhaps when
conducting research I don't know but so
your attention span might not be as good
as it might be because of the constant
bombardment exactly yes thank you any
more comments well I think when these
gentlemen probably started out they had
only a couple of journals hardcopy
whereas we have basically the entire
internet so I think
you just have to have a better filter
but still great great breakthrough as
you mentioned don't come around like
every other week that doesn't happen I
think nowadays you have often the
impression that you have so many options
on alternatives that might be a bit hard
to focus on one specific goal I do think
that one of the most important
challenges for the educational system
nowadays is to teach students how to
select information that they can find
and find on the Internet and in that
sense it's very important to be able to
use the media as an opportunity rather
than a threat what's the phrase that
does seem to be a bit of a kind of
generational divide I think how people
approach their work today and how your
did yes I don't think it's as dramatic
as has been described because we were
not faced with two journals but many
journals and we were faced with having
to read these journals rather than to
access them quickly we had to go to
library so it was much more time
consuming that than it is today you can
get information much more quickly today
which is good then you think that it's
time going to the library and that kind
of thing thank Tom Strom is an economist
once you're here I don't think we think
very much about Nobel Prizes when we do
our research so I think the key is you
is the nature of research and how its
evolving so it gets to the issue about
has it sped up or something like that
and in economics at least despite all
the journals it turns out that it's
harder and takes longer to get
publications but maybe the whole
function of publications has changed
professor photonics and the internet
started with physicists circulating
their papers at CERN so the now there's
a huge overload of papers coming in with
is a advanture physics
everything is put on the archive almost
immediately and of course it's it used
to be easy to read what was put out
every day or every month but now there's
so much coming in again you get down to
this filtering problem
it facilitates our work no doubt but I
miss something which is to read an
article by accident 40 years ago I used
to borrow you know and to take a journal
just holes and and all of a sudden you
know you find a nice drawing you read
the paper you read it more in detail and
this is totally accidental and it's a
good accident nowadays you read what you
are prepared to read you go to a journal
on the internet and I mean just look at
what you want to look at there are no
accidents anymore so nip serendipity sir
and isn't always left ok sure thank you
well that some interesting thoughts
there but let's some now take some of
our first questions from the audience
and Rebecca loading your question please
so remember when I was supposed to
choose a degree for university that
basic science was not a very popular
field to go into among the students in
my class so how do you think we could
encourage more young people to be
interested in and wanting to pursue a
career in basic science analyst over
recent studies and surveys show that
nowadays young scientists are under
extreme extremely high pressure to
publish to secure funding and
tenure-track positions and this often
leaves a very little energy and time to
to do high quality research and to
pursue interesting ideas so what is your
perspective on this and you and Pam my
question is what is your opinion towards
a global trend of reducing funding for
fundamental fundamental science research
thank you very much let's take that last
question first from un pan about the
global trend he says reduced funding for
fundamental scientific research so
Fraser I mean do you see a difference in
research for fundamental and applied
scientific research no I don't I think
there is
no difference between fundamental
research and applied research I think
there's only good research and I think
the to marriage into each other very
nicely I spent time in industry and it's
some very fundamental work when I was
with Imperial chemical industries
corporate laboratory and that is where
most of the ideas that led to my
discoveries in the early 90s came from
so I've never seen this them enough
situation I've just seen good research
and maybe not so good research gentlemen
who'd like to become some of those
points that we heard people talk a lot
about the pressure to get tenure I mean
the that you have to do a lot to get
tenure and that makes people write a lot
and all that but actually if you when I
look around and see my colleagues who've
got tenure many of them also seem to
continue to produce many papers and I
think the reason they do it so they
don't read they're not under the pro the
gun anymore but they still do it it's
not just to get grants it's because I
think to some extent they like to feel
busy and they like to be able to tell
people what they're doing and actually
it's quite difficult to be engaged in a
long term project because then you know
where you meet someone they say what are
you up to well not much you know nothing
working in places it doesn't set in once
they got the tenure put their feet up no
no and but the thing is I'm not I think
that you you would hope they would then
say oh I'm now free to do a 10-year
project but I think it's mentally
difficult to do that I always give my
students that want to go into an
academic career the following advice
walk on two feet one going a line of
research where at least you get some
decent papers so that you can write a
grant application or people recognize
that you do some decent work and then
work also on some very challenging
question where you might not have a
paper in the next three or four or five
years but where you will make a name in
the world for yourself
of course that's risky the debt will
state said the states maybe for your
next career so yet you cannot deny that
there is a pressure to publish some
papers because without papers you
not have the possibility to get a grant
on the next step or tenure or so but you
should focus on what are important
questions because we forget that
sometimes that the main purpose of
science is to ask the right questions so
about all this information and knowledge
it's it's great to know a lot it is
better to ask the right questions
mm-hmm professor consulates one question
was how do we encourage more young
people to go into science it's a I think
that's a very difficult thing to do
because if you think about it for a
minute
most people who go into science
okay they go in very enthusiastic study
hard etcetera etc but the chances of
being very successful are actually low
and so you're never going to get rich
for example and maybe chemistry medicine
it sounds different but certainly in
physics you'll never get well rich doing
it so what I know you've got your prize
now that you're you're sharing well out
you reach the very top a little bit
thank you yeah it's wonderful to have
this price but if you think about is
monetary value its monetary values not
much not after the taxman has battled
escape has had this cut so no money's
not the thing it's more the satisfaction
of doing of producing something in
physical but how do you know what which
piece of information is is significant
and which is not some 99.9 percent of
the stuff out there it's not so
significant this is noise and the one
and the point one percent that is
significant out there
you've got to know it's significant oh
it's significant you have to be familiar
with the subject so it's it's it's a
very difficult problem hmm you obviously
have identified that no point one
percent I think that one of the things
that's overlooked in this conversation
is that mentoring is very important it's
a and and when you ask you know how how
can we improve the on the system I think
if we maintain a good mentoring system
that is critical and I don't think these
other things changes that much it came
through from your comment about about
you know giving advice to students so I
have been I would say I've been very
lucky to have a wonderful mentors one of
which sits in the audience here having
good colleagues and so on and I think
looking at it as a monetary issue or
Boqueria consignee student it's just far
too narrow who is your mentor here
what Bilson is sitting in the corner
there all right put your hand up Bob
he's not just my mentor he's a mentor of
of many many fine students and two Nobel
Prize winners
it looks very young to be a mentor but
anyway there we are thank you our next
question please
from Kirsten Copeland recently it seems
as though governments and the general
public rejecting experts and ignoring
their advice where in the past it was
held in much higher esteem what do you
think is driving this trend thank'd
Holmstrom you worried about experts
advice being rejected by public opinion
I'm worried about the public rejecting
the the not just experts but the sort of
representatives and that have the
ability or should have the ability to
process complex information and today's
situation seems to be characterized by
people thinking that they can go
directly to the source and not have
anybody interpret it and therefore they
are very subject very much subject to
misunderstanding what is going on and
and so yes I'm very not a bit elitist
though that oh complex issues there to
be understood by the experts and
ordinary people if you're capable of
working it out themselves
yes but the latest doesn't mean in this
context that it needs to be bad so you
know this is a this is really part of
our democratic system that there are
some people who know more than the
others and not before not necessarily
because they're smarter or anything like
that but they have just have been handed
a task to process the information on a
broad
basis and what assumes that be happening
now is a sort of total almost rejection
for for this principle you know I think
some of the I don't want to call it
distrust of experts but sort of working
around them isn't so bad I mean for
example you know once upon a time if
there was anything wrong with you went
to the doctor and you assumed that what
the doctor was telling you was the truth
now you can go on the internet and find
out get a lot of information about what
might be wrong with you and I think that
can be actually productive sometimes you
can end up knowing more than the doctor
about a particular thing or but at least
being able to bring to their attention
something and I think there's a
difference between that and you know if
you go on the web and you look at things
carefully and you might even read some
journal articles you don't want to
exaggerate your competence to understand
them but you can get a sense of it I
mean that's a good thing and and figure
if you did that say with global warming
you would undoubtedly end up with the
conclusion that the science says this is
a really serious problem what's worrying
is when people find somebody who says
it's not a problem and focuses you know
they then focus on that
yeah there's a whole tsunami of
information the real point that we are
all facing is of course quality of
information what does it mean how are we
going to educate our young people to
distinguish what is right how are we to
make the information available to the
general public and probably be a
scientist have to do a much better job
to distinguished facts from fiction and
opinions you cannot develop a smartphone
based on an opinion sir Frazer I mean
specifically on this the brexit vote and
you know experts and politicians seeing
their advice rejected that that caused
you a great deal of angst why it did
we're going to enter an era of hard
brexit then this is almost like a
chemical reaction that is close to
irreversible and that saddens me I was
at the forefront I feel when I was in
the UK and
field and what early in Birmingham
bringing in students from all over
Europe and then all around the world
when I left to go to the United States
we were something in the excess of 15
different nationalities in a group of 30
to 40 people this was sheer magic this
switched on the students from the
British Isles in a remarkable way as
well as you know really raise the
standard of our research and so I'm
saddened by the fact that the people
working in chemistry at the highest
level and the UK could be faced in the
near time by having to go down to
pulling on population of 65 million
instead of 500 million
Kirsten you were you happy with what you
heard I mean what's the answer to your
own question oh I suppose I mean for me
doing my PhD has been invaluable in
allowing me to consider how the
scientific process happens how to
approach something as a skeptic and to
look at the evidence and I think I feel
like that's something that's missing
perhaps in in the general public's
mindset they tend to take what the media
gives them and ingest that rather than
perhaps being as critical as it should
be
thank you very much Andy okay so we'll
go to your specific fields now gentlemen
for which you won the prize and let us
sum start with them economics professor
Hart and professor Holmstrom the Nobel
Committee said you won the prize for
your separate work on contract theory
the judges said your work laid an
intellectual foundation for policies in
areas such as whether workers should
receive a bonus incentive or ordinary
salary where the essential public
services should be privatized and they
said there was these were matters
valuable to the understanding of
real-life contracts and institutions
Oliver Hart you see parallels between
your work on incomplete contracts what I
could term bad contracts and why people
in the UK voted brexit how does your
work on contracts area expel
the brexit vote well I don't want to say
it explains it like there are parallels
because in my work I've looked at
contracts between two commercial parties
and I've argued that in situations where
it's hard to write a good contract what
becomes very important is who gets to
decide on the things missing from the
contract I call that residual control
rights and that sometimes goes together
with ownership of assets now in the
political context if we if we take you
can think of the European Union the
arrangement that all the countries have
in the European Union it's like a
contract and you could have them you
could imagine in a sort of ideal world
that everything would be written down
and advanced and then the whole European
Union would just have been about the
negotiation of that initial contract
well of course that's not you can't do
that so instead you set up these
decision-making bodies and I think that
well that what British voters felt was
they'd allocated a lot of that power
that residual authority to the centre
Brussels has called it away from the
individual countries and I think people
past felt they had done too much of that
by the way I was in favor of remain I
didn't want to get very quickly on this
issue of breaks it were you all opposed
to it including the two europeans Dutch
and French were you all opposed to
brexit well interesting all our Nobel
laureates at the table four of you
British to European so you all opposed
to brexit okay banked Holmstrom your
research looked at whether contract
incentives how contract incentives
affect corporate behavior and you know
whether performance-related pay works
and the difficulties in assessing say a
teacher's performance as you said it's
not as easy to measure as say a factory
worker and how many goods or handbags or
whatever they may have manufactured so
in terms of the workplace what does your
searching to contract theory Telus I
think the big insight in some sense in
my view is that they were very focused
initially on thinking and incentives
need to be provided by financial
instruments of some kind or other or
contract and we have come to understand
how big a part of incentives is actually
something entirely different than what
most people think as incentives like
bonuses or something like that so
complementary at people doesn't
necessarily do it's not just about money
but yes I know the sort of stereotype
view is is throwing money at people or
you know in there's an incentive problem
let's incentivize them be some money
actually that is most definitely not the
main main approach the world takes
really so much to ask you when we have
all these debates particularly in the UK
about executive pay and executives
getting big bonuses and salaries because
share prices have gone up in their
company or whatever what's your answer
to that does it not make economic sense
to pay these big checks it's not so much
how big they are
I mean size matters but you know what
worries me much more is how they get
structured and especially what these
candles and other things have got have
led to in terms of how they are designed
so I think I think we have gone from
some arrows that could have been
corrected say 20 years ago or so in the
designs into much worse designs because
of the public being upset and the
regulator's being upset and they are
trying to really solve the problem of
levels and not thinking so much about
the incentives so I think they are gone
from from maybe a somewhat flawed system
to a much more system also moving to
another area of research that you
awarded your prize for was this question
of whether for public providers of
services that whether they could be
privatized for instance the Obama
administration's to the Prison Service
which was privatized should no longer be
provided you know by private companies
you also see a live debate in Africa for
instance about where
education should be publicly provided or
provided by the private sector so
professor Hart I mean what does
economics tell us well I think you did
it can be helpful I wrote a paper with
co-authors about this issue and I think
you know what we say in the paper is you
know one extreme would you privatize
nuclear weapons we thought no I mean put
them in private hands didn't seem like a
have a contract with someone who holds
the nuclear weapons probably not a good
idea would you privatize the State
Department would you have a contract
with a private company to run foreign
policy I don't know whether Donald Trump
is thinking along those lines but I
don't think I don't think that would be
a good idea he has appointed a
businessman I think that so maybe he's
moving in that direction but at the
other extreme garbage collection rubbish
collection quite comfortable with that
it depends how good a contract you can
write and you know what kind of things
can go wrong and therefore who should
have the residual control rights that's
it that's how to think about these
things schools are somewhere in between
in between when you have competition
that strengthens the case for
privatization so in the case of schools
you know the school does badly is
shading on quality then people will
eventually find out it may take a bit of
time but yeah and they'll send their
kids to a different school in the case
of prisons we probably don't think it
would be a great idea for the prisoners
to be able to shop around and so you
know their competition isn't going to
work as well and that strengthens the
case for public provision thank you very
much so let us turn to chemistry and the
you chemistry laureates the three of you
were jointly awarded the prize for
fundamental chemistry the Nobel
Committee said you have mastered motion
control at the molecular scale the
design and synthesis of machines a
thousand times thinner than a strand of
hair so small that tens of
of them could actually fit on a pinhead
so we've got some questions I think from
the students here if I could have the
first one
Olaf Johnson your question yeah so what
are the fundamental limits to how small
you could make these certified
machines okay great if we could take the
next one held up Bergman so I wonder in
20 years time where do you think you'll
see the biggest use of molecular robots
word for example be in medicine or
molecular electronics Thank You Bennifer
Inga let me take the first one with you
what are the fundamental limits to how
small you can make an artificial
molecular machine because in 1999 you
led the first research to produce a
molecular motor that continually spins
in the same direction and learning 2011
your group built a four-wheel drive nano
car yeah it's very difficult to say what
the limits were doing but we work with
molecules and typically our molecular
motor is half a nanometer or so so and
one nanometer is one billionth of a
meter as you know so the limits will be
probably in that size but you have to
realize if you want to build machines
it's only the moving part is only part
of the machine so you have to integrate
it for instance you have to put it on
the servers or integrate in a device etc
so that is that all depends on the type
of molecules you are designing for a
specific purpose if you look in your eye
which has a beautiful switch yeah it is
the tiny molecule in the in the eye is
probably one nanometer but it's part of
a big protein complex that makes it
possible that the signal of the light
that comes to your IDE triggers this in
your eye and then changes and there's a
cascade of process that make it possible
that you get the signal in your brain
the fact that I can see you when you can
see lead affected ourselves can defy
that we can move our muscles these are
machines of a of a couple of nanometers
at most M Sean Pierce Sivaji mean you
managed to make one molecule pirouette
around the other in a controlled manner
when energy was applied
so our question about where do you see
the biggest use molecular robots in
medicine or molecular electronics the
question was what's your answer to make
it clear I have no answer I have I have
comments you know before our
contributions it was considered as
extremely difficult to set molecular
systems in motion I mean we knew
everybody knew that there were plenty of
such motors and machines in the
biological world but using artificial
systems molecules which had been made in
a laboratory that was considered almost
impossible and I think that was a big
step in a way that the three of us and
our co-workers but just the
questionnaire I assume is thinking wound
you know but when she asked about
medicine is that you know we think about
the walking microscopic robots which
could for instance slip inside the human
body and deliver drugs in a targeted
manner yeah perhaps perhaps it's the
phrases the question we had about any do
you foresee any negative social or
environmental challenges with the misuse
of this technology that we should be
aware of and I should say that you made
a key advance by threading a molecular
ring on to a rod like structure that
acted as a dumbbell the kind of thing we
use in a gym when you added the two
together the ring jumped forwards and
backwards like a tiny shuttle and later
you built numerous molecular machines
including a pump so that was your
particular contribution but what's your
answer to the question well if I could
take the latter part first and just make
a comment about the movement to Aquarius
Ben Farina has promoted the movement in
a circular sense a rotary sense I think
jean-pierre and I with our row taxing
based systems molecular shuttle based
systems have done the a fundamental
preliminary work to achieve movement in
a linear direction
but it's not just sufficient to have
that movement in a willy-nilly type of
way we have got to be able to direct
that movement the first step after you
have the willy-nilly type of movement is
to go to a switch there's still a lot to
be done in terms of going from switches
to machines machines have to do work and
this has been a progressive situation
from finding how to bring about this
motion in either a rotary or a linear
direction to a switch to a machine you
would you like to see opportunities in
your either discoveries you've made
would you like to see them develop I
mean been freeing up
do you see great opportunities is I I
definitely see a greater position as my
colleagues already said it is very very
early days so this is fundamental
research the breakthrough that you can
induce motion responsive functions in
materials opens up an entirely new field
of material science and machines
ultimately maybe science fiction at this
moment but in 30 40 50 years from now I
see many opportunities during my whole
career I work together with industry
also on potential applications and and
so we have close contact them and when
we and this counts for for the whole
community I think if we see
opportunities for cooperation we will
work together with industries but you
have to realize to bring it to a product
in the market might take a long
development trajectory develop a new
medicine at this moment takes more than
12 years and there lots of money so this
is typically the timeframe we are
working in it turns out in my laboratory
in recent times by working in this area
we have serendipitously gone off in two
completely different directions one is
to create very highly porous materials
that as the basis for one startup
company starting about 15 months ago
that is looking at use of these porous
materials in home care in personal care
in food and ultimately in
pharmaceuticals and the other one is a
quite serendipitous discovery that I
would never have even predicted and that
is that we are looking at new ways of
isolating gold that get us away from the
use of cyanide which is 83 percent of
the world's isolation and the other 17%
is mercury 2 very nasty chemicals and
all of this has come out of fundamental
research and both of these are
serendipitous discoveries going on while
we're making molecular machines thank
you all right thank you very much indeed
chemist laureates I turn to the
laureates in physics
Duncan Aldo Michael Kosta let's and also
David Thewlis or all of your British
born and David alders professor Palace
is not with us but our congratulations
go to him also you were jointly awarded
the prize for discoveries for your
pioneering work on strange forms of
matter the Nobel Committee said your
discoveries had opened the door on an
unknown world now Mike oscillates along
with David Thewlis you focus on
phenomena that arise in flat forms of
matter on surfaces inside extremely thin
layers that can be considered
two-dimensional unlike the three
dimensions that you know we describe
reality around us with and the work
involves a field of maths known as
topology topology basically I suppose
analyzes the shape of things it tells us
that a doughnut in a wedding ring
topologically are the same thing and do
duncan of ordains studied
one-dimensional matter so that's a kind
of preface to the question that we have
from our physics student flora kunst
sorry and do you think there will be any
technological advancements such as for
instance quantum computers coming from
the new insights in quantum mechanics
ever provided by Ortiz most probably yes
I mean to what we really discovered was
that there were more interesting
materials than we expected and condensed
matter physics is a fancy name for
understanding the properties of
materials and what this work is really
led to it started off with
one-dimensional things but it's not just
one-dimensional or two-dimensional
there are a class of materials which we
didn't realize existed before that have
very interesting properties in their
quantum mechanical structure and the
core mechanics is a fundamental way to
understand all materials and the
topology is a side issue in a sense that
we discovered the some very beautiful
unexpected properties of quantum
mechanics and the mathematical tools of
topology turned out to be very useful
for analyzing the specific differences
between these unexpected forms of matter
and conventional matter so this whole
analog about Brett's pretzels and bagels
is just that the bagel has a hole in it
is different from a football which
doesn't and this new form of new new
kinds of condensed matter are also
different from the familiar tight as the
bagel is for the football the the
property of having the hole in the bagel
makes it slightly different you can you
know pick up the bagel and they can get
you can look through it you can poke
your finger through it or whatever but
it it's just different it's not good for
playing football with no it's not good
for playing football but it will change
the game as I said right so it professor
consulates and we have heard that your
work could result in improved materials
for electronics and that could lead to
superfast computers okay this is it
doesn't like the question no no it's not
I don't like it I just fumbling for an
answer to that because let me let me
stress that when we wouldn't we started
this work it was it we had no thoughts
about applications or anything like that
it was nothing more than an interesting
theoretical problem there was it you
knows there's a theoretical question
that we wanted to try to answer and
that's what started it all
sure but could it I mean in theory in
it's different one can see all the
difficulties as well as some of the the
possibilities and the question was
asking what the possibilities bunk and I
can see many of the difficulties with
unanswered difficulties right so we
simply don't know the answer to the
question well leave the physics there
then could we go to our next question
please
in Geller linked off I um so we've all
noticed that there are no women I
received the Nobel Prize this year so my
question is what can you as Nobel
laureates us as young scientists but
also general public do to encourage
women to go into science and promote
them
well I volunteer to start that one in my
own view of this this issue is an issue
no question about it but my own view of
this issue is a bit heretical and you
cede to me the the female of the species
is actually very too smart to go into
physics so simply because physics is
tough education no question about it and
the resulting job you're going to get
with this fancy education is not great
and it doesn't pave particularly well
and it doesn't give you much free time
so why on earth should somebody whose
earth who is sensible and tells Guenter
at this difficult field when they can
make a much better living in easier
field is so heretical that your fellow
laureate right disagreeing shake
I save my views erecta cuz I thought
fantastic job if you because it gives
you the opportunity to discover things
and to work on advancing knowledge now
if you wanna people it's not badly paid
I disagree that it's bad paid it's not I
mean people that if you want to make
huge amounts of money of course you go
to Wall Street or whatever but the issue
with women in physics I mean physics
department certainly energy states are
very tremendously focused on I'm trying
to do something about this the the we
believe probably it's a question of
maybe its role models to be able to see
successful women scientists and so
people believe that they can have a
career in it we really do wish women to
come into physics and there's a problem
of women becoming discouraged and
dropping out at each stage of the
process there's a experiment that they
have done in in auditions of musicians
and they have started to audition behind
the curtain it changes dramatically the
amount of the number of women that
they're very accepting so it just shows
that there's a lot of discrimination I
know it's not an evil discrimination I
think it's just subconscious we are a
club you know we men behave in a certain
way we understand each other better we
don't understand women very well you
know the Fraser your late wife was a
scientist yes as are your two daughters
yes
what's your answer on this gender issue
why does it happen that we don't have
enough women and what can you do about
it
well I think it's a changing environment
and I think we will see over the next 50
years a dramatic change if I speck
express it in terms of my own family I
think my two daughters who are sitting
in this audience with PhDs and chemistry
are living in a much different social
and home background and even myself and
my wife where they are supported by
husbands who are playing a big role in
running the family looking after the
children and so I think we've seen
social changes that will make it very
much easier for women
participate in the furtherance of
science and so I'm very optimistic that
it's going to come about maybe one year
in the future there'll be seven women
sitting around this table optimistic
comments and I think we can end that
particular area of she just want to end
by saying of course normally we would
hope to be joined at the table by the
laureate for literature and this era
force it was Bob Dylan I should also say
actually of course we don't have with us
professor Yoshinori or sue me who is the
Nobel laureate in medicine or physiology
and our congratulations go to him too
but in terms of Bob Dylan there have
been some comments saying that the
songwriter perhaps shouldn't have been
considered in this category of
Literature Prize job here you reacted
there so well what do you think I like
him as a senior I like the music but I
also have difficulties to believe that
there are no writers you know very
recognized writers who wouldn't deserve
the poise as well all right very
diplomatic answer perhaps saying that
anybody else Bob Dylan Ben I think it's
fantastic that Bob Dylan got this award
I mean he his poems his songs were so
important and influential for a whole
generation you know when I was a student
I had these records and I still know
every one of it it's it's great and when
it was announced in a typical laboratory
like mine every Laborde has his own
music and within a minute they all
switch to Bob Dylan really he said he
was rendered speechless when he received
knew he'd been awarded that it's got bad
words influenced his words the influence
people you know it what you know it
seems to me that's literature okay
good choice professor consulates I think
you're a big fan aren't you a personal
point of view when I heard that the
Literature Prize be rewarded to Bob
little I thought wow that's the greatest
decision I've ever heard of
wonderful why I ain't loved Dylan and
his and his music and and songs I really
may drop I essentially grew up with it
do you do karaoke for bobbed it of Bob
Dylan's right I once I once tried it I
mean I can't you don't want to give us a
burst he'll absolutely not Mac can't
sing
I have something heretical to say about
Bob Dylan which is I think and we spent
far too much time talking about Bob
Dylan well I don't I don't mean here all
right I mean just generally you know is
he coming isn't he coming I actually
don't care I mean he didn't come I mean
it seems to me it may have been a fine
choice but probably if he had come he
would have sucked all the oxygen out of
the event so that's partly I think good
thing he didn't well I shall take up
your recommendation and stop talking
about and in fact gentlemen we will stop
talking about anything because that's
the end of this program thank you to all
you laureates and renewed
congratulations thank you to our
audience here at the concert hall in
Stockholm and thank you to you of course
wherever you are in the world watching
this program for me Zainab Badawi and
the rest of the team on noble minds
goodbye
[Music]
you